Europe keeps up with climate targets
even as it faces multiple other crises
European countries are among the largest
historical consumers of fossil fuels
that have caused the climate crisis
that's why the continent has to cut
emissions faster giving developing
countries the carbon space to pull
people out of poverty and provide their
basic needs but Russia's war on Ukraine
has caused Europe to rethink its future
with access to Russian gas dwindling the
European Union has been on a mission to
find fossil fuels from wherever it can
get them those moves are making people
question Europe's commitment to its
climate goals the blocks answered to
those questions is to double down even
as its emissions are set to increase in
the next year or two it is keeping the
total emissions budget the same over the
decade that means a small increase in
emissions now less than five percent
will have to be met with faster
reductions later in the decade it's not
going to be easy the risk of missing
those targets goes up the longer it
takes to reach them but Europe is
legally Bound by those targets that is
why the European Union is plans and
place to meet them those involve
voluntary reduction in gas use faster
rollout of Renewables Banning the sales
of gas powered cars and others it could
be doing a lot more to insulate homes
and nudge citizens to reduce energy use
done right those steps will help it deal
with not just the climate crisis but
also the energy crisis and high
inflation if acting on climate change
wasn't already complicated Russia's war
on Ukraine has added to the difficulties